this video is brought to you by squarespace
whether it's your new profession or just a
lifelong passion start your journey to website
glory with squarespace check out their amazing
all-in-one platform through the link in
the description below more on them in a bit
go looking through us presidents from
the first half of the 20th century and
you'll find a surplus of icons teddy roosevelt
woodrow wilson fdr and harry truman are still
famous for being among america's greatest leaders
while warren g harding and herbert hoover are
famous for being the exact opposite heck even
william mckinley and william howard taft remain
known one for being assassinated the other for
being so fat he was practically a walking your
mum joke yet the most fascinating president
of this era is also likely the one most of us
have never heard of calvin coolidge rarely makes
lists of best or worst commanders in chief outside
political history geek circles his five years and
seven months in office are barely remembered yet
they constituted one of the most quietly radical
eras that washington has ever seen as president of
the 1920s coolidge oversaw a roaring economy even
as he trimmed government spending to the bone when
he left office it was as a conservative hero a
man who'd brought prosperity so why isn't silent
cow better remembered today the answer lies
in a tale of excess prosperity and heartbreak
in terms of over-the-top symbolism it's hard
to beat a future president of the united states
being born on independence day but that's exactly
what john calvin coolidge did entering the world
on july the 4th 1872 like a living metaphor
yet this well-timed entrance would turn out
to be a rare flash of bombast in the quiet
life of the 30th president and we don't mean
quiet in the sense of boring we mean he literally
barely ever spoke growing up in picturesque but
hard scrabble plymouth vermont young calvin
absorbed the family trait of speaking only when
absolutely necessary even the boy's father who was
a merchant into legislature and thus expected to
occasionally talk to people treated words like
expensive chocolates dosing them out in small
doses and only on special occasions compared to
his son though the man was practically locatious
calvin coolidge grew up so silent it was a local
joke that he was mute for the boy muttering a
greeting was a conversation while exchanging two
sentences was like launching into a soliloquy
while that quietness was in his nature though the
boy also relished the opportunity that it gave him
to observe as most kids his age were playing
or studying coolidge seemed to be absorbing
life lessons storing them away in a special safe
deep within his soul he noted for example the way
debt crushed family friends a fatey swore he'd
never endure he noticed too the way his father's
economical use of speech wasn't a hindrance at
town meetings but almost a superpower a way to
ensure no one could ever throw ill-advised words
back in his face much later coolidge would remark
of his own taciturn nature the things i don't
say never get me into trouble yet there were also
times when perhaps more should have been said when
coolidge turned 12 his mother died of tuberculosis
sent in to see her one last time he was merely
told by his father not to cry in the aftermath
of her death there was mourning but no grieving
the two men simply never spoke about it much as
they would keep silent when coolidge's sister died
it's back to these twin tragedies that some today
trace coolidge's temperament irritable
melancholic and difficult to be around
but you could also just as easily trace back to
them his drive to succeed years earlier coolidge's
grandfather had left the boy 40 acres on the
understanding that he continued to work the hard
vermont soil like his family always had instead
following his sister's death the boy suddenly left
plymouth traveled to amherst to get an education
there coolidge was unwanted by the fraternities
forced to live instead in boarding houses this
turned out to be a blessing in disguise as it
allowed him to gradually level up his social
skills he didn't really do small talk but at
least every sentence no longer felt like a double
colonoscopy where he did start to excel though
was in making speeches it sounds counterintuitive
i mean a guy for whom hello was one word too many
was happy to get up before an auditorium and
wow them for 40 minutes yet it seems coolidge's
natural reticent simply melted away in these
formal settings in the sheltered world of college
he was free to discover his hidden talents he was
also free to discover his political beliefs one of
coolidge's tutors at amherst was professor charles
garman a guy who regularly turned his lectures
into pians on individual liberty property rights
and conservatism under his spell coolidge began to
identify more and more as a republican by the time
he graduated it was no longer enough to return to
plymouth and get into farming no the young man now
had another destiny one it might be even harder to
reap rewards from than the cold northeastern
soil coolidge was going to get into politics
normally when we do videos on presidents who
came up through party politics like lyndon
johnson or richard nixon there's a section where
their career takes off like a rocket ship calvin
coolidge's rise by contrast was like watching a
snail climb up a stepladder rather than the name
straight for the house or senate coolidge instead
set his sights on the city council in northampton
massachusetts where he moved after graduation only
five years later did he bolster this with a run
for the school committee a race that he lost but
rather than shrug his shoulders and move on silent
cow went back he analyzed what had gone wrong he
tried to figure out how he could have turned the
loss into a win when he next stood for election
he'd used that knowledge to secure his victory
for the rest of his career coolidge never lost
a single race and so silent cal began his slow
but unstoppable rise through the massachusetts
gop he became a member of the state house of
representatives then mayor of northampton then
a state senator and then a lieutenant governor
as he rose he began to develop his politicals
in 1912 coolidge mediated a textile strike in
lawrence and came away convinced a pro-business
anti-strike position was the only one to take
that same year he threw his lot in with william
howard taft's re-election bid divorcing himself
from the republican progressive wing personified
by teddy roosevelt more important though may have
been coolidge's time in the state senate there
he realized the work of government shouldn't be
passing endless laws but actively revoking bad
ones that the state passed fewer bills while he
was said at presidents was long a source of pride
for him still we don't want to give the impression
that coolidge's life was nothing but politics
there was also time for romance for a man as dao
as coolidge loved to be the story of how he met
grace goodhue is unexpectedly sweet a teacher at
northampton school for the deaf silent cow one day
heard her laughing through an open window and was
so enamored by the sound that he resolved then and
there to date her they married in 1905 leading to
the snarky joke that grace taught the deaf to hear
now she might be able to teach the mute to speak
by the time the wilson presidency got underway
coolidge was a happily married father of two with
a solid career as a conservative lawmaker who
was independent enough to track left on stuff
like women's rights and immigration in the 1918
race for massachusetts governor this combination
was enough to land him the job he was sworn in
the following january just in time for the crisis
that would make his name the boston police strike
was a mass walkout over the right to form a union
suddenly without cops the city plunged into
chaos and looting but rather than do as everyone
expected and cut a deal coolidge went on the
attack ordering the state guard into boston to
restore order coolidge fired all the striking
officers declaring there is no right to strike
against the public safety by anybody anywhere
anytime it was such a forceful reaction that his
friends begged him not to sign the order saying
it would end his career instead it turned coolidge
into a national hero the lawlessness in boston
had horrified the nation people saw the police
officers not as regular strikers but as deserters
who surrendered the city so when coolidge crushed
the strike america applauded even woodrow wilson
came out in support of him from a solid but
unremarkable governor calvid coolidge had
suddenly become the hottest property in politics
just as the election year of 1920 dawned
not that his party was currently looking
for anyone popular or principled to lead it
the 1920 republican convention saw the affably
corrupt infinitely clubbable warren g harding
handed the nomination in a shady backroom deal
angered by these shenanigans the rank and file
delegates rebelled forcing one of their own
picks onto the party ticket as vp coolidge was
in the governor's mansion in boston when he got
the call that a voter insurgency had landed him
the vice presidential nomination his wife grace
asked if he was going to accept i suppose i
shall have to he replied with characteristic
understatement and just like that coolidge's
path to the presidency was set now if you want
your path to a great website to be said you've
got to visit our longtime sponsor squarespace
this is the age of creation people are making new
things on the internet all the time you probably
know someone or maybe you yourself want to start
something online and when it's time to move that
project from your head onto the screen in front
of you and get it out to the world that's where
squarespace comes in it's the perfect web tool
to help you turn the internet into whatever you
want it to be maybe the hands-on type with lots of
opinions and ideas about what exactly your website
should look like if so very cool squarespace gives
you all the customization options you could ever
want me no updates no patches no technical bs
to worry about or maybe you just need something
functional something that works with minimal
thought so you can stay focused on the content
and not just the coat of paint well just use
one of their quick beautiful templates to make
a website that's both fresh and simple and once
you're done setting up your website locking in
the name playing with the colors if you want well
there are so many extra features that squarespace
provides that your website can thrive email
campaigns patronage portals social integrations
member only areas analytics commercial options 24
7 customer support everything you could ever want
in one place so when you're ready to get started
on the next project of yours big or small it
involves a website it's gotta be with squarespace
right now you can go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch your site
go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics
to save ten percent of your first purchase of a
website or a domain and let's go back to quark cal
come the 1920 election the question wasn't if the
republicans would win but just how much of a blah
victory was on the cards after eight years of
wilson's progressive agenda after a war that had
killed 116 000 americans after a deadly pandemic
and amid a deep procession people were simply
ready for change warren harding capitalized
on this running with coolidge under the slogan
a return to normalcy without ever telling anyone
what exactly that meant not that this ambiguity
mattered that november harding and coolidge
demolished their democratic opponents james
m cox and his vp pick franklin d roosevelt thus
making coolidge the only person to ever defeat fdr
in a national election it was a landslide win a
sign the electorate was ready for real republican
leadership unfortunately what they got was harding
and his dodgy mates sucking the nation dry as you
might remember from our video on him ron harding
and his ohio gang were of the go big or go home
school of corruption in his three years on
the job they did everything from sell off the
navy's oil reserves to their friends to steal
life-saving medicine from veterans hospitals
luckily for coolidge though they never once cut
their vp in on the action as far as the white
house was concerned silent cal was a boring sap
they'd got lumbered with the lame millhouse to
harding's devilish bart so they basically ghosted
him gouledge had little contact with harding's
team even in congress coolidge's role as senate
president was sidelined by gop majority leader
and harding powell henry cabo lodge it was a
time of immense frustration for coolidge but it
would also save his career by 1923 corruption
under harding had gotten so extreme ranging
from extortion to unleashing the doj on political
enemies the senate had started taking note before
the scandals could break though harding went and
died of a suspected stroke on hearing the news
it said that henry cabot lodge turned pale and
cried in disbelief my god that means coolidge is
president as indeed he was the day harding went
off to the great pig trough in the sky coolidge
was vacationing with his family back in plymouth
far away from any telephone line by the time the
messenger reached the house the vice president
was asleep he was woken in the night by his father
now a justice of the peace and told to get ready
coolidge got out of bed prayed and went downstairs
in the early hours of august 3 1923 silent cal
stood under a kerosene lamp in a darkened room in
his childhood home while his father administered
the oath of office at 2 24 am coolidge officially
became the 30th president of the united states
the drama over he went straight back to bed as
if nothing had changed but of course it had
dimly aware of the brewing scandals coolidge
became president just as revelations of harding's
misconduct exploded just as during the police
strike the new president responded ruthlessly
harding's crimes were open to investigation while
his old ohio gang were purged from government
although coolidge tried carefully at first
afraid of uncovering too much corruption in his
party ahead of the 1924 election all of the 29th
president's lackeys had soon been cold-bloodedly
dispatched from washington amid the booming
economy of the 1920s this show of force was enough
for voters rather than punish coolidge for his
proximity to harding they instead rewarded him in
november 1924 coolidge carried over 54 percent of
the vote securing himself a full term the era of
clearing up harding's mess was over from now on
coolidge would be his own president while his term
would never be as dramatic as hardings it would
still manage to radically reshape everything
washington thought it knew about government
the arrival of a monosyllabilic president was a
field day for american satirists h.r mentioned
famously declared that president coolidge's
ideal day was quote would be one in which nothing
happens but while this was meant in jest it does
get to an essential truth not that silent cow
wanted nothing to ever happen but that he wanted
the federal government to do as little as possible
conservative to his core coolidge believed that
businesses should be left to themselves that the
states should take care of their own affairs and
that washington should aim for blissful inaction
combine this with his penchant for taking
long afternoon naps and the 30th president
got a reputation as a man with all the spirit of a
recently deceased dodo yet coolidge wasn't lazy he
really believed america could basically run itself
once saying if the federal government were to go
out of business the common run of people would not
detect the difference the only time he got really
animated was where money was concerned throughout
his tenure coolidge obsessively cut government
spending even dictating what color bags the
postal service used in order to save a few pennies
he became one of the few modern presidents to
run a budget surplus something he called among
the noblest monuments of virtue but it wasn't just
spending coolidge slashed taxes also got the knife
with the top rate plummeting to 25 percent still
the lowest on record since world war one among
the not rich majority of the population federal
taxes dropped to effectively nothing and all this
cutting and light touch regulation really seemed
to work the coolidge prosperity is basically what
we think of when we think of the roaring twenties
growth was strong wages soared unemployment fell
and money was everywhere it sounds great and for
most people living through it it probably was
yet but be lying if we said there wasn't a
dark side to the coolidge prosperity the 30th
president was so committed to small government for
example that it sometimes eclipsed his humanity in
1927 catastrophic flooding along the mississippi
river inundated an area the size of the republic
of ireland two hundred thousand people were
displaced and whole communities were ruined yet
coolidge was adamant the affected towns should pay
for the damage themselves it took the secretary
of commerce herbertova to convince him to
begrudgingly launch a federal relief effort
similarly a federal anti-lynching bill that
had been championed by harding was quietly
dropped by silent cal who felt the groundbreaking
legislation would have infringed on states rights
but the darkest side of all involved the thing
coolidge loved the most business as the second
half of the 20s roared into view wall street was
doing a worse and worse job of regulating itself
speculation was out of control elsewhere the
agricultural sector was in dire need of help
yet coolidge never intervened and well we all
know where that ended still hindsight is 20 20.
it's worth noting that no one in coolidge's time
saw the wall street crash coming no they were
too busy enjoying their great gatsby star parties
and moving jerkily to the distant strains of jazz
broadly then life was good in the coolidge years
so good that everyone expected him to run for a
second term in 1928 and to win but there was one
person who wasn't enjoying the coolidge prosperity
despite being at the very heart of it as his
term wore on the 30th president began to spend
more and more time sleeping long epic slumbers
that soon left him with as little as a four-hour
workday in his era coolidge's hypersomnia was a
not-so-secret joke a strange quirk of a strange
president but in the last couple of decades a
new theory has emerged one that could explain
a lot about is one term what if calvin coolidge
wasn't just some quiet dude who liked naps but
someone in the grips of a depression so
deep he could no longer see a way out
in summer 1924 less than a year after his
dad's unexpected elevation to the presidency
sixteen-year-old calvin coolidge jr stepped onto
a white house tennis court for an impromptu game
it was a regular day nothing special if he had
watched calvin jr and his older brother play their
set she wouldn't have thought anything about it
but after a few games it was clear that something
wasn't right in his rush to get on court calvin jr
hadn't bothered to put on socks now a blister had
formed on his foot causing him to cool off the
game that boring unremarkable afternoon nobody
thought much of it it was just an interrupted
tennis match there would be plenty more in the
future it was only when disaster struck that
people would think back to that game to that
afternoon and see the roots of the tragedy that
would soon consume the white house within days the
blister on calvin junior's foot to become infected
in these years before penicillin there was nothing
the family could do nothing but watch helplessly
as the infection became blood poisoning calvin
coolidge jr died on july 7 1924 a little over 11
months into his father's first partial term as his
son slipped away silent cal sat at his bedside
a locket clutched in one hand in the locket was
a picture of his own mother who died all those
years ago and a lock of her hair he pressed it
into his boy's palm until the boy could hold it
no more his cabin jr died the locket fell from his
fingers the death of the family's golden boy hit
the coolidge is hard both the 30th president and
his wife grace were plunged into a deep depression
as coolidge later said of the day his son died
the power and the glory of the presidency went
with him among presidents only a handful have
lost their children while serving in office most
famously abraham lincoln but there's good reason
to believe coolidge suffered more than any of them
having never properly grieved his mother or his
sister the death of calvin jr seems to have simply
broken him it was in the aftermath the coolidge
began sleeping as much as possible drifting away
from life from the pain of his memories for up
to 16 hours at a time he showed nearly all the
signs of major depression from an inability to
take joy in things to viciously blaming himself
for everything that had gone wrong some days he
seems to have done little more than to put
his head on his desk close his eyes and weep
now we don't want to overdo this during his full
term coolidge was hardly bedridden with grief he
worked to cut taxes liaised with his cabinet held
regular press conferences he was even capable of
dry wit such as when he responded to a woman
who said she'd made a bet that she could make
him say more than three words at dinner with you
lose in short he was functioning but functioning
isn't the tame as actually living somewhere
deep beneath that cold mysterious exterior
a tiny spark seemed to have gone out in its
place came nothing but a weariness so vast
that it eclipsed everything the loss of calvin jr
affected grace just as badly in 1927 she appears
to have had an affair possibly with someone
connected to the white house there's evidence
that coolidge found out and so we come to the
final act of coolidge's presidency in the summer
of 1927 silent cal passed a note to reporters
who'd come to document his family vacation
it simply read i do not choose to run
for president in 1928. at the time the
announcement caused shockwaves to this very day
what caused coolidge to pull out is still hotly
debated but whatever the rational reason it seems
doubtful that the image of calvin junior slipping
away wasn't somewhere in the back of his mind
haunting him as he would for the rest of his life
at the time coolidge handed the baton over to
his former secretary of commerce herbertova
he had every reason to think history would smile
kindly on him he'd overseen a prolonged economic
boom that lifted americans out of poverty he'd
pushed the international kellogg bryant pact
committing nations to avoiding war it forged a
new less aggressive policy towards latin america
it kept the us out of the league of nations he
achieved a balanced budget in fact coolidge in
1928 was so popular that republicans tried to
get his name on the party ticket refusal to run
be damned silent cal had to practically beg them
to instead nominate hoover not that the gop needed
to have worried who was elected in a landslide in
a large part by playing off of coolidge's legacy
so yeah it seems fair to say that as coolidge
left washington in march of 1929 that he felt
sure of being remembered but of course that's not
what happened that october the collapse of the
financial system and subsequent great depression
killed the 30th president's reputation people
charged that he'd seen the collapse coming when
he decided not to run for re-election that his
policies had single-handedly created the economic
catastrophe with nearly a century of hindsight we
can see these charges weren't true there were
so many intertwining causes of the depression
that it's doubtful anyone could have averted it
still coolidge could have done more and the public
seemed to recognize this just like harding years
earlier coolidge's post-presidency reputation
was soon utterly trashed tragically he wouldn't
live long enough to see his rehabilitation
calvin killage died of a heart attack on january
5 1933 as america stood on the cusp between two
eras behind lay the wreckage of the roaring
twenties and the prosperity coolidge had been
so proud of ahead lay the uncharted waters of the
new deal of fdr an era that had no place for men
like silent cow today calvin coolidge
is arguably the least remembered 20th
century president washington has no significant
memorial to him there is no presidential library
even the coolidge auditorium in the library of
congress is named for a patron who just happened
to share his last name in scholarly rankings
too coolidge remains obscure often appearing
right in the middle of the pack he's surrounded
by other non-entities like grover cleveland and
james a garfield and yet despite his near
invisibility silentcal has still managed to
have an outsized influence on the modern world 51
years after coolidge left the white house another
president came in with similar thoughts
on government known as ronald reagan one
of his first acts was to hang a portrait
of coolidge in the cabinet office to help
inspire his own conservative program it's a sweet
irony of history isn't it perhaps the most obscure
20th century president inspiring one of the most
iconic but then that's calvin coolidge a man
who could sometimes be small sometimes
great sometimes playful sometimes depressed
but what he and his presidency never
were was anything less than fascinating
so i really hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching